- Kay I hope it's okay I know if there's
a difference let me know I'm currently
two out of two 11th place
people have 16 points already and I have
my four points white looks perfect right
now that's good okay congratulations
Braden you've earned the mod title
I've been modding a lot of people
recently I'm gonna have to start his
irking this guy only rated less than
1800 berserk every game in one jeserac
good night thanks for watching
mods everywhere yeah still lagging a bit
yeah it's it's lagging because I'm
uploading a video to YouTube in 20
minutes it should be ok the YouTube
video is at 75%
I'm buzzer King I'm playing e4 we're
gonna try and kill this guy quickly
which is maybe slightly contradictory to
the stream title but it's okay I'm
playing one of my pet lines against a
French which isn't great against good
players but it's usually pretty nice
against not-so-good players because a
lot of people wonder in this exact
position by castling hopefully this guy
isn't watching the stream Queen b6 is
also a fun line for white if I remember
correctly because taking on me 2 losses
immediately according to stock fish but
I have to remember what soccer says
pretty sure Knight p5 is just trapping
the Queen
I remember I show the student this and
my student like called me the last round
of a tournament or before the last round
of the tournament
she was playing someone she was playing
for first place and all we knew was the
guy played the French and we had like 10
minutes to prepare so the only line I
showed her was this line and she got
this position over the board with 95 and
she won the Queen and then she went on
to draw the game it was so sad but it
was amazing opening preparation so
White's threatening 97
I think lights also threatened something
like Queen e2 rook b1 or Queen d2
repeating one there's some like simple
queens wrath' I forget if we throw in
like rook e1 first at a pawn and move
back I don't think it matters
I also remember like wait if black
castles I might be able to take on h7
and that actually might be the top
stockfish move so there's going to be a
couple possibilities
I would guess casting is the most likely
move and then I have to decide between
Bishop take h7 and Queenie to Bishop
take h7 might run into King take h7
Knight g5 King g8 Queen h5 Queen takes
e2 and he defends h7 oh but now I'm
remembering my prep is that okay let's
imagine this is a good calculation
exercise for people so if you Castle if
he castles the I'm just basing this off
my memory with stockfish I'm pretty sure
Y can take take
Knight g5 King g8 and it's not to play
queen h5 because that runs into Queen
Dixie - this is also just a common Greek
gift like type idea - so the point is
after King g8
White has a very strong move queen d3
preventing Queen take c2 and then after
g6 play Queen h3 that should be winning
somehow but King g6 also interesting but
King g6 looks really fun I just start
harassing the king like still probably
Queen d3 to calculate king g6 Queen g3
i-5 and then Queen g3 looks very strong
something's gonna work hopefully this is
a fun line so if there's anyone watching
who doesn't know it to play against the
French I highly recommend I call this a
- Knights attack it might have a
different name but basically start off
this you play d4 and you kind of give up
the D pawn but you you focus on piece
play so he's thinking Oh Brandon's been
bringing up the time so I try and teach
all my students to checkmate with Bishop
and Knights even if they're not very
high rated so yeah that was like that
was crazy like we looked at Bishop at
night and then a week later longer the
odds anton squared me giving some very
thoughtful advice when it comes to
calculation the rule with calculation I
guess there's a couple rules that people
live by you either sacrifice first and
then calculate or calculated than
sacrifice okay this is gonna be fun
Queen d3 I'm sure he he saw Queen age
I mean take c2 but he didn't see Queen
d3 and I'm not sure if light is just
mating or if I can survive somehow
I'm g6 Queen h3 I think it's just over
if f5 still probably queen h3 like it's
so important to provoke either f5 or g6
so it blocks the blocks of diagonal from
the black Queen defending so the
geometry is kind of nice in this
position chess havoc has played this
variation as whites
oh it's recommended in a book
interesting I don't really read books so
I don't know what he's talking about but
that's cool certain man SC loves my
lectures but watches I'm at 1.5 times
speed so maybe I don't talk fast enough
maybe I should talk faster but then
maybe some people would have to watch it
reduce speed can you watch like can you
change the speed on youtube videos I
guess you could L ignorant a is being
ignorant a and he didn't listened to me
earlier or maybe he wasn't watching
which is a definition of ignorant a if
Queen h5 in this position Queen takes c2
and black defense so I had to provoke g6
and then and then throne made on h7
I think it's force mates right he has no
stupid Bishop take F to know this should
take F to prolongs a game but yeah micro
cafe so that was nice let's 14 moves and
that was actually all opening
preparation to Oh
just a matter of remembering the Queen
Queen d3 move it's not the easiest move
to remember because it's different than
most great gifts but okay hopefully some
inspiration to play that line for for
the white side against the French six
place ooh
and I bezerk that game and I'm on the
streak life is good Oh Chrome extensions
that's interesting it's good to know
okay so just waiting for a game this guy
lost which is good from Indonesia nice I
was just there top two players still
haven't lost any games ooh
this guy's higher rated than me what
country is he from okay I'm playing Sam
quadruple five if you please f4 I don't
really know what to play against f4 I
usually just play c6 and it's just a
game of chess and I'm like g6 maybe not
the most challenging opening but and try
and make two already curious if I can
play like d5 and we get some we probably
got some really like closed sort of I
want to call this caro-kann and I don't
want to call this French closed sort of
structure where usually black is OK
giving away the light squared bishop and
I'll try and submit my knight on f5 with
some move like h5 and an e6 and it tends
to be very positional actually it might
resemble a French very soon because I'll
end up playing c5
and black doesn't necessarily want a
Castle kingside I think I have to take
this but very often the King can just
stay in the center and the center will
hopefully stay closed I should know that
I'm not worried about Queen d5 usually
met with Queen d7 in the meantime I just
want to build up pressure this is a
little bit interesting because you might
want to take on c5 and win upon so move
like knight c6 could run into just pawns
at c5 and then he plays b4 so I don't
want to be careless I could take the
bishop but I like my knight I got five
so what to do hmm good point
ninety-seven my nut doesn't want to be
on d7 there's Queen b6 actually see an
interesting line with Queen b6 because
it could lead to trading a lot of stuff
but I'm calculating take take take take
the bishops get traded and I checked the
king it would probably play King each
one okay he doesn't go into that never
mind
b3 I don't know if I understand yes he
is defending the b2 or the b-pawn so in
many lines I can't take it
oh I didn't even realize I was starting
to take on e3 and take on b2 so he's
just a friend a let's play Knight c6
good evening
what's his name again is it just Gabriel
I think it's Gabriel good evening
Gabriel
okay cool yeah I have one more hour of
these of slow slow but rapid games it's
an oxymoron I'm not used to playing this
time control sometimes I don't know you
don't know what to do with myself and my
opponents thinking I guess we could try
and like tribute to what White's gonna
do here there's a ton of pressure on d4
I also have ideas
I mean blacks just trying to win upon
here where I could take on you three
first I could take on d4 first so I'm
guessing he either has to take or play
rook t1 but there's problems for him in
some lines like I was just about to say
it 41 I might be able to just take the
take and then take on d4 or and if he
takes can I take again a nice rook takes
Bishop c5 he does have Knight f3 in the
very end might kill the fun I could also
just take on d4 right now and see what
happens I think that's good enough
his d4 is attacked four times and solely
defended three times and the only hope
for him is to make use of this pin but
his bishops currently attacked so I
think blacks are swinging upon hopefully
I don't regret it
ooh maybe I do regret it I may have
miscalculated that but we'll see what
happens hmm actually I think it's still
okay I'm trying to avoid saying anything
cuz I know he might be watching
um I don't want to like accidentally say
a winning line for whites but I'll talk
after he moves nose knows all I like
this time control because you have time
to explain your thoughts yeah I guess
that's a difference between like bullet
and blitz and this time control is there
is time for talking and explaining
that's why this is slow and instructive
also better to learn because we can look
and see what we would do
cool okay that move was not the move I
was scared of I was slightly scared of
take t4 which I think was still okay but
it gets a little too complicated because
Knight take d4 Queen f2 I would have to
play Bishop c5 oh but then there's
nothing for white for some reason I
thought there's Knight f3 but I'm simply
and I take f3 with check ok so had
things under control this is just a
really nice position for black because
targeting the King already up upon if he
doesn't move his queen to f2 there's
gonna be some very nasty discoveries I
think giving me so many options here
probably just might take b3 unless
there's something better we might take
b3 just once a rook
okay I take p3 it is uh Suso certs
where'd you live that you are streaming
in this hour
uh Chicago Midwest it's 11:00 p.m. but
it's not too bad I'm a night person
so usually awake at this hour so I may
have lied when I said I was wearing a
rook might just be the exchange but that
should be good enough I just have to
watch out for annoying counterplay rooks
you want a rook c8 looks nice rook c8 he
could go crazy and take on d5 positions
like this you just want to minimize any
sort of like annoying counter play just
like get the King safe prevent your
opponent from doing everything they want
to do so I'm imagining rook c8 might
take d5 pawn to d5 Queens 85 he's
frightening to different mates in one on
f7 and d7
black still might be okay there but I
don't think I want to go into that line
just looks scary
I think Bishop d7 looks a lot more safe
I'm just preparing to castle
I was hoping for some night person puns
given your last move what was the last
move night I don't even understand that
comment ok this should be very safe for
black
I'll just Castle kingside
and then activate the rooks on the C
file I guess one important point is that
he can't really use this f6 square like
he would like he would love to get a
knight there but there's no night path
which gets him there safely and
meanwhile I just want to start making
drets and usually when you're up the
exchange you want to look to dominate
the only open file so oh he wants to
play Knight f4 in sac on g6 uh-huh I
could play Queen d4 and just repent that
can also play Queen a6
I could also just play rook c8 what to
do so many options Queen before he has
rook be one then Queenie faux-fur ok
Queen before our safe move you said you
were a night person
oh I am a night person but I don't have
any Knights in this position ok we're
gonna keep going here and Queenie for it
looks like a very nice central square
for the Queen
if he doesn't trade Queens I'm i-25 he
does trade Queens it's just easy when
I've been winning but I haven't been
winning quickly like only nine
Tournament points if I want to be
competitive in this chart in this
tournament I might have to deserve at
least a few games and my opponents are
taking their time - this is tough
Mario war is seven leading the
tournament 24 points I think he's the
highest rated player okay let's take on
you five so black is up to exchange and
three pawns if I can do math it's a lot
of material
okay 94 finally get to play the move
I've wanted to play for a while got
really no harm in this position can drop
the Queen back to e4 drop the Queen up
to e4
I'll work see choose the threats this
will hopefully be over relatively
quickly I understand why he's not
resigning but I wouldn't like it if he
resigns uh what to do good play Rex eats
him anyway that complicates things a
little bit but he takes my queen I take
his queen I'd be okay with some trade
the best players must beserk most of
them yeah I guess if you want to win
tournaments like this the zhurqis is
crucial in bullet - that's true so yeah
depending on the rating of the my next
opponents I get there below 2000 I'll
probably bezerk and hopefully I won't
regret it
but okay so winning this position he
plays Queen 85 okay keeping Queens on
the board oh yeah all threatened maiden
one maybe he'll see it maybe he wants
good move I don't want to waste time
playing a six but should I
let's play h4 let's go for the kill yes
it is important for black to be patient
in positions like this but given the
time situation I'll be a little bit in
patience Queen g3 Queen take a7 where is
my breakthrough okay I'm gonna start
with Queen c4 and then probably when the
a to pawn better 182 pod yeah this game
is gonna go on for a bit longer
let's take honey - you might just end up
flagging it's probably the most likely
scenario at this point he could win the
h4 pawn my next move is probably Queenie
for Queen is in prime position and his
Queens if like he doesn't want to trade
Queens he basically has to play Queen g3
then the plan is to bring the other work
in double up on the second rank get the
job done hopefully
I guess if I play rook cc2 he does have
Queen b8
she's a little bit than playing queen
bee a queen bee aids okay fine also a
move okay I'm gonna play rook be to you
he wants to target f7 but he has no way
to further attack f7 without allowing a
queen shade and the simple plan was to
play rook e1 and get rid of his rook and
then then make use of my rook c8 somehow
Braden Laughlin slow chess is the best
chess I don't know if I could agree with
that but I'm performing decently so far
okay let's play rook e1 and then if he
doesn't trade rooks I'll try and meet
him if he does trade Brooks I'll still
try and made him someone wanted rook AC
to wait what's a c2 in what position
oh that position I don't know they were
very similar I'm gonna continue being
safe just like we need for I could have
gone for a rook c1 but the too crazy for
me
s chess is the best chess now we're
talking
b5 okay I'm gonna try not to forget to
dessert thanks game so that's a solid
game it started as a birds opening and
it somehow transposed into some French
structure I traded off flights for
dishes and then I got the typical French
pressure on d4 I'm a pretty smooth game
so far most of the games have been just
matter of getting some like material
managed and then converting no real
challenges yet this is a prime opponent
to race against he is buzzer King - okay
we're gonna have some fun so now it's
just a blitz game will play a night of
six play d5 g3 interesting play Bishop
e7 there's a move I like to play your b5
simply preventing c4 sometimes catches
white off-guard
a4 simply before I don't know if this
opening has a name anymore like started
as some Catalan but it's kind of in
weird territory now did the Youtube
upload finish I haven't even checked you
- oh it's processing nice so it's done
uploading now it's just processing
that's good he plays c4 probably a good
move sometimes it's a question is my
bishop on a B on b7 or a six
actually don't know let's start by
putting it on b7 and then there's a very
typical move coming up for black with
especially with this sort of position is
to play Knight F to d7 well maybe I can
play Knight bb7 might be g7 C six take
take that doesn't work okay Knight ft7
it looks weird and passive but I think
it's necessary and White has some push
with space but as long as you can't play
c6 and it's gonna be one of these like
closed middle game structures let's
throw the pawn on e5 and the goal is to
put the bishop on a6 at some point we
might trade nights then somehow
activates this Knights
let's just play Bishop basics maybe I
could have played Bishop a six in one
move I don't know there's also some
possibility of playing r6 and then make
him choose what to do with the Knights
there's also a possibility of playing f5
she's very committed but it gives me the
e4 square I'm gonna start with f6 let's
see if he wants to trade okay he doesn't
trade um I might just play f5 here or
maybe I'll I don't know cuz you might
want to play e4 some problem okay I'm
playing at five it looks terribly or
terrible positionally because he has 95
but I have 94 so it's a trade off
that's some kind of stone wall structure
now debating whether to play c6 I might
as well play c6 and put the Queen on c7
but the 97 it's a sill in wall structure
where my bishop actually has a decent
square did I miss something
to the thymus Knight g4 earlier I just
glanced at the chat and saw Brooke f2
like triple question mark but now I
think it's a missed opportunity
maybe I wasn't paying attention I'll
have to go back after this game and see
if I miss something really easy I was so
focused on positional chess and on
tactics okay 97 I'm not sure if I want
to play 94 right away or do something
else he trades off his bishop mmm let's
put the work on e8 first now 94 looks
attractive because I'll have that file I
know he's going for g4 but if he takes
on e4 which I think he's gonna take at
some points
I might be able to double up also
keeping the time advantage which is good
Bishop III makes some sense I'm a
throwing King ehh it's usually a very
useful move in these positions where if
lines open up on making side
I want my King as safe as possible I
also might want to play g5 a typical
attacking move let's play g5 looks fun
there might be some eventual threat of
g4 in the meantime I might reorganize my
rooks
I put the rook on a7 with other organ g8
to support any pawn breaks so this is
what I was talking about earlier with
that file opening is I have some more
scope but he's attacking g5 let's play
Queen d8
I didn't wanna play h6 because he had H
for this position I probably want to
play h5 now the one problem is things
might liquidate really quickly and just
be really Josh like here everything's
super closed
I didn't seem that f3 I didn't see a
knight of 3 because I can just take it I
was like I was about to play rook g8
that was weird
thank you for the Knights I guess that's
why he's rated below 1700 can pre move
this okay
nice game tough one he was playing I
think he was playing okay but did I miss
Knight g4 work f2 someone said Rick I
have to triple question mark oh did he
have Bishop h3 wait what oh so it's just
kind of a positional moment I don't
think there is any huge missed
opportunity visitor of h3 made
better maybe I would still go for a five
I don't know but Bishop h3 is isn't
moving these positions okay some talk o
beyond the mask is back Wow long time no
see I'm scrolling up the first message
it's been a long with long in all caps
time since I've caught a stream
yeah I've been streaming slightly more
regularly at least the last few days the
last two and a half months I've been
traveling a ton so it's hard to keep a
similar schedule and then this coming
weekend I won't be streaming or maybe I
will be streaming I don't know I have a
tournament starting tomorrow but maybe
I'll like do some like quick streams
like just showed what happened in my
tournament games that might be
interesting John Bartholomew does like
YouTube videos like that or at least
he's done them recently but yeah now
that I'm back in a place with better
internet I can I can stream on a more
consistent basis and I am making an
effort I know I haven't been too long
long-term but my website I am rosen.com
has my stream schedule if you just click
on schedule you'll see upcoming streams
right now I think if you go there it's
just protests League matches which I
might be doing commentary for again and
let's play E for I was boring someone
earlier at the London I'm going to use a
same similar opening I use against the
other guy never mind
I was gonna say two nights attack but
this is more of a what is this called
caro-kann modern I didn't know if this
has a name now I actually don't really
know too much theory here I shouldn't
really take too long I know at some
point White's supposed to play h3 like
after d5 prevent Bishop g4 Knight f6 is
a little bit strange because like I'm
wondering if I can't just play e5 then
he has 95 mm I shouldn't take too much
time here let's just play a normal move
Bishop to e3 a chess addiction no it's
not a virtue key nice it's a virtue team
north which is a little bit smaller but
still competitive ooh he's playing like
some what do we call this the rack
variation like C 66 I'll probably go for
Queen c7 in E 5 and these positions
become very positional a4 is meant to
stop him from expanding with B 5 e 5 I
think I can play rook e1 and not worry
the idea is to just get the bishop out
of the way like Bishop f1 and be solid
yeah one usually white maintains some
slight edge but these positions are
usually at fights but at least the next
few moves should be very easy
Bishop e3 Queen d2 but maybe not c5 is
played c5 looks weakening I play Knight
f3 problem is this d5 square for him
Bishop g5 rook d1 this pawn is sort of
backwards 95 potentially in the future
Bishop c4 all the whites pieces are
about to come to like really good
squares so this is exciting
Gabriel is asking about Geum run and Mar
is asking if I have an eg uniforms
I'm not taking the G
wait do I want to do that first yeah I
want to thank this g5h six bishop each
for it is still good for whites yeah I'm
not really taking it too serious too
seriously about getting to GM because I
don't have any norms my feet a rating is
23 60 something I think so if I were to
get one norm I would probably try and
work for it but right now I'm just
trying to use chess to enjoy myself and
to travel to cool places so that was
basically the goal of my recent travels
as I played three tournaments overseas -
in Australia one in Indonesia and none
of them were like tournaments for a GM
norm but they were just cool to like be
in new environments I'm gonna play rook
t1 d6 is about to fall and I do have to
manage my time a little bit better I
guess he has 98 here but then he five
that's nice I win the pawn and exchange
and actually like the queen is very
limited on squares like queenie 8 i
don't have to take right away I can try
and torture him like five the rooks
trapped I'll probably go and take on b7
maybe win the a6 pawn I'm just trying
with all his pawns
Gabriel asking if I've been to Brazil
actually the very first international
tournament I played was in Brazil and
[Music]
when was it it was 2011 it was a World
Youth Championships I was my only time
playing that event it was my only time
qualifying for that event for the US and
it was the last time I could qualify cuz
I was 18 that year
and you have to be 18 or younger to play
okay let's try and finish this guy off
what to do I could take on g4 mmm I play
Queenie for I don't know let's take on
g4 first and then some simple like rook
t2 nothing too crazy I'm tempted to move
the Queen back like Queenie for actually
here it's just a very simple skewer I
don't know if he can defend the the
Knights it's just waiting material I was
mainly playing Queenie for to just
resent relies the Queen and prepared
Bishop d3 but yeah why sweating a ton of
material here so yeah when I went to
Brazil it was a very random place like
middle of nowhere this town called
called us Novus a kind of a nice resort
town let's take the knight because he's
attacking my rook let's take with bishop
because his bishops hanging his Rex
hanging is how their brook is attacked
which I don't want to take right away
Queen e6 was the best move there let's
take this rook and probably with d6
yeah called us no this was actually
really nice
sometime in November it was actually
over Thanksgiving and let's play 95 here
everyone I met at least all the
Brazilians I met were really good at
soccer if we played soccer like during
the tournament and before the tournament
so the stereotype is true and it was a
nice resort to good memories okay what
to do looking for some sneaky mates but
maybe they don't exist take em okay I'll
be patient put the King on each one
probably the Queen goes to h5 should be
good enough maybe I missed a cleaner win
I don't know I'm trying my best
I think White's threatening some force
mates I'm not mistaken
maybe I am mistaken I don't know
just that what to do
Bishop b4 looks nice let's play Bishop
before I'm just trying to make him out
uh on each seven or it might even have
lycra kh6
does that work for ticket six and that
works this if the King runs I have Queen
g6 mate and then okay that was a nice
game some weird opening light was
slightly better the highlight of this
game was c5 I think this is a turning
point where like black has to be much
more patient
the c5 was just way too weakening he
should have played like Queen c7 maybe
Bishop d7 bring the rooks to da dun da
then just kind of weights and it's
usually a very tense position but I was
uh I was pretty brutal what happens
after c5 so I'm trying to catch up to
this guy but he keeps winning but I am
buzzer King this guy yeah the guy in
first place is playing it looks like so
I probably won't play him
Braden's asking about c5 Knight d b5
which maybe was possible I think I
played 9 f3
I mean if 90 b5 1 the d6 pawn and I
should have probably played it but
Knight f3 was good enough I think yeah
so Knight DB 598 only question is if
black plays a6 where am I putting the
Knights from b5 or maybe I can keep
attacking d6 I don't know
I think I'm missing a lot of comments in
the chats
it's hard to keep up and play games so
I'm in the berserk again focus on this
game another efore you for treating me
well today f6 let's take it so this is a
common trap where Queen h5 is met with
g6 and black is actually winning because
my take g6 quintic e4 so yeah it's kind
of a a garbage trap but sometimes it
happens this I haven't seen before d5
this is a new move for me now I have to
think I'm guessing just d3 white gambits
upon plays Bishop e2 it should be a
great position
seems like this guy's books but let's do
it just using my intuition Bishop g4
okay I think I can play Bishop e2 no I'm
threatening to take so he'll probably
take up remove this he doesn't take on
e4 so he's getting ready to Castle
queenside the problem for black is this
f6 pawn is just hideous
and he's very slow to develop the Kings
side so it should be good for light
somehow Queen g4 is interesting it
prevents them from castling queenside
cuz queen take a7 the Queen d4 Queen c5
I don't know point a4 actually looks
okay let's do that I defend efore as
well and I prevent him from queenside
castling and I'm just controlling the
center so looks okay uh yeah Queen a4
getting ready for Bishop e3 I forgot he
could play Queen b4 but then we'll trade
greens and it becomes positional which
I'm not too much against
beyond the mask is asking if we're going
to do a simultaneity 99% no because I'm
tired and this this is a long tournament
like I've joined at the beginning of the
tournament there's still 25 minutes left
but maybe there will be some future
Seibel this will take we'll play C 3 and
then we'll Castle maybe Black has almost
achieved equality wondering if a four
could be strong a four okay I'm just
gonna play for a base on intuition
I mean if Queens on the board a for it
would be a no-brainer but in this
position
I'm simply threatened to drop the bishop
and this question of what black does if
he commits a pawn on the Queen side I
would have some musician 'el play and
some something I don't know I don't know
what I'm saying
Bishop d6 I think is bad because I play
a five
I'm not trapping the bishop but I'm
kicking the bishop a lots and I gain
space just ready to complete development
what was I trying to say
oh yeah if you plan to move like c6 I
would have expanded with like b4 and
then potentially b5 so King b8 kind of a
slow move but maybe necessary
I'll play tonight a3 going for 94 or 95
two ideas ie five so might be five looks
nice
after he's defended I might win the
bishop hair I might even win the pawn if
he's not paying attention but I would be
happy to win a win the bishop hair in
the position like this where it's
relatively open and it's some end game
where bishops are gonna be dominant I
could take on a 7 with check and he
can't trap me but he could play c6 in
the end but then I take on d6 so this is
actually a serious calculation bishop
take a 7 King 8g take F 3 c6 Knight 86
take on a 7 and 9 f5 looks ok hopefully
I'm not missing anything
might even have like a six possibilities
some immediate attack the basics
probably runs into v6 yeah so white slip
up on white has a bishop pair c6 is
critical but probably not that great for
him I even have he plays he's excited
Bishop b6 preserve the bishop and attack
the rook that looks nice
so good position just have to manage the
time c7 is not defended I don't know if
I can take it there might be a really
cool move here Bishop d6 but I don't
know if I want to calculate that they're
there they're there their King runs to
c8 oh I really want to play Bishop e6
but I want to spend all my time let's
play Bishop e3 there may have been like
some beautiful mating ideas in that
position but who knows
c6 normal move I could hop in makes you
76 mm I want the night to go to b6 but
that's hard to do let's just do this at
some point I do want to play a six
if he plays rook these six sides decide
between night hd7 tonight see five a-six
looks fun here
it actually looks like White's getting
some mating attack because all the
pieces can play a role in the attack so
yeah a file opens he probably should
have gone for b5 I'm like King AIDS but
now with a file open and I'm gonna
double up black should not survive this
[Music]
in deduction was saying a6 earlier maybe
I don't know maybe I had a sex earlier
who knows now the threat is made into
it's very hard to stop actually yeah
this is just lost nice game that was
maybe a useful opening to know for efore
players out there it's Queen e7 trick
don't play Queen h5 and whites should be
better with this poem f6 just really
slowing down blacks development okay I'm
in second place I'm gonna try and
continue to Burke and catch up to the
sky he's played so many more games than
me it's tough and I'm probably not gonna
play them because he's in the middle
game of his game over birth again taking
some risk but we'll see how it goes
oh he's buzzer King - okay let's play
Sicilian um I'm gonna switch it up
Oh an open Sicilian we're gonna play
accelerated dragon Bishop e2 I actually
don't know any theory in the slime the
only thing I know is like d5 can be
played at some point maybe right now
let's play d5 right now
seems like this guy knows what he's
doing though I have no idea what I'm
doing
brand-new opening for me rook b8 looks
like a normal move 25 looks sort of
normal let's go with Queen e5 pretty
sure black wants to attack on the Queen
side last game I was confident in the
opening but this game it's gonna be a
challenge rook b8 looks normal again
it's all about initiative like
especially these dragon positions you
have to attack quickly and efficiently
maybe e5 at some point if he lets me
just grab Center then like d4 he plays
e5 mmm that's probably a good move
94 probably not good 94 this is a piece
okay so I have to play Knight d7 which
has some positional value attacking the
pond maybe ideas of nice e5 e6 wow
that's just a free pawn looks like a
free pawn
I want to fly e5 he wants to kill me
though
h4 so aggressive I could threaten meat
hmm actually h5 is pretty serious
threats as I fight you try myself he has
g4 immediately so what to do F choose
hanging pawns don't matter in this
position I have some sneaky idea to
trade Queens let's start with Queen me
for I think he has to play B 3 and then
Queen f4 is the points I saw Queen
before like initially after he played h4
it but I just forgot to look further
like what else could he be thinking
about here b3 only move may be queen g4
okay but Queen f4 happens and blacks up
upon and E 5 is coming I'll be a nice
center cap remove this yeah life is good
so probably just have time for like one
or two more games after this so I don't
know if I'll catch up to that guy that
guy needs to lose and I need to win the
rest of my games
so just expanding want to play for next
don't probably play f3 but the center is
reinforced I could play I don't know
what to play let's start with e 6 the
idea being to over defend the d5 pawn I
want to play g5 but he has h6 and then
micro page 5 so let's play Knight f6
here
and we like his trade and he has h-file
but I might challenge him at some points
I will admit like probably has a little
bit of compensation but it shouldn't be
too much hopefully yeah I just want to
connect the rooks let's start with
Bishop b7
I didn't play Bishop d7 because I want
to say that's Bertha tonight in case he
attacks e5 now I just want to play rook
a Jade's and he can't really I don't
think he can do anything quickly enough
Oh is Rick h2 a nice lip maybe uh you
wants to play rook g3 which I can allow
put the rook on each six positional
let's play 97 the tame as night my plant
earlier was to play c5 sooner rather
than later just expand but here I don't
think there's any rush for black like
everything's pretty well defended I
might start with some improving moose
like rook bh8 King f6 maybe c5 Bishop c6
so he's challenging the center I think I
can just ignore that let's play rock
edge AIDS
doing well on time I do just want to win
this game quickly though have time for
at least one more game I think I'll play
c5 very soon like c5 Bishop c6 oh he
wants to play f4 but f4 could be met
with you four okay so I'm just
continuing to improve the one annoying
thing my work is kind of stuck defending
this pawn so I might actually want to
play rook g8 at some points or even g v
g5 looks really nice I forgot about that
move okay now I could probably just take
the knight yeah let's take the Knights I
never my knight c6 looks like a nice
square d 4 + f4 on the horizon hmm
that's annoying I can't play King e6 cuz
Rick take g5
there's no tactical tricks so I have to
play this it's still better for luck I
just didn't want to commit to d4 so
early his rook is actually kind of stuck
on g3 which is nice so I think the plan
from here I mean just continue to
improve put the knight on the good
square bring my rook to b8 bring the
other Brooke into his territory
just play quickly Oh any tactics with
the bishop let's start with her be it
threatening to take on d3 so he plays
that let's do this
anything to play rook e3 this rooks are
just super ridiculous this bishops good
but his rooks are a laughing matter but
what I'm just kind of stuck I can't win
b3 right away let's play a five
positional g4 good move let's play rock
h8 bring the knight c6 take so he's open
the G file like sacking exchange
it's pretty nice Evan I'm gonna try and
made him somehow or not we're just
trading everything it's a winning
endgame somehow for black at least it
should be we'll win the pawn and then
promote something ooh
tricky was about to creme of t3 okay
nice game
hopefully time for one more game I am
within catching distance of this guy but
it looks like he's winning this game I
think actually it's complicated so yeah
I don't know if I'll finish the next
game in time for it to count for the
tournament but we'll see
perfect score so far doing some nice
things for my rapid rating
I haven't played rapid chess in a while
okay next game over there so we'll see
what happens I'm gonna try and play
aggressively but that might be hard to
do against whatever opening he's playing
he's playing the London okay this is fun
already we're gonna play the sign with
Queen b6 he plays Queen c2 which i think
is a move queen d3 is a main move
can i play Bishop a5 here then he takes
on c5 so I think I take first I forgot
there's like a clear way to punish this
makes with Knight really I shouldn't
take too long here taking with Knight
looks weird let's start with g6 and play
a bit differently than normal
we'll take care black has some decent
center someday the dream is to play e5
if I can prepare it and maybe 9 h5 my h5
looks nice so I think it gives me the
bishop air and it prepares me 5 which I
can play it right away
and then I'll take mmm whatever kind of
good square actually night be three can
walk into a five Queen b3 okay mean that
looks like it loses upon and a queen
that was a bad move by heavy you're just
attacking everything and attacked four
pieces with one move we'll take the
Queen so he gets her ripped for it she's
not resigning
I'll just complete developments so not
too much to talk about here
he keeps attacking my queen retreat to
safety and then I'll expand looking to
play an e4 and actually I'm looking to
like just target him on the dark squares
because I had I still have the dark
square bishop
so like e4 in Bishop e5 and queen d6
looks fun enough
mara 5 9 8 yes
sound of excitement sadly why cannot
just make a move a black moment wait
what
ok we're gonna try and beat this guy
quickly please play King inch - that
would be nice actually anything is nice
here for back and he can't defend the
Jeep on booking each it was the most fun
fun way to proceed and sadly I'm out of
reach of mario wars 11 is pretty much
guaranteed to win the tournament but
maybe I'll pass other guy take on g3
booty top I could take the rook mmm do I
want to take the rookie I do and take on
h4
I could have played Queen h4 right away
maybe but at this point anything is
winning its flavor b6 trying to figure
out if he doesn't resign the quickest
way to meet it's probably some like III
queen f2 let's start with III then Queen
f2 I could just win the bishop he's
still not resigning we're gonna play or
though we're just gonna take Bishop at
some point I'll take g5 fish about five
and bring the rook over maybe even
Bishop efore start with g5 threatening
Maiden - okay I made them - I could
creme appoint f2 right okay that's nice
so I think that's gonna be the last game
yeah back to tournaments o pairings are
still open but it's okay it's ten minute
chess it's gonna close any second now
but maybe I'll have one more game I
don't know so I beserk slike the last
whatever four or five games too many
fives there as buddha' top still playing
who he is
so he could pass me if he wins in like
two minutes but that's what happens
maybe I should have dessert the first
the first two games or all the games and
I would have maybe past 40 points people
in the chat second place well done
it can never be satisfied with second
place but that was fun
hopefully that was more instructive than
usual streams compared to playing
bullets I do have a challenge from
someone who wants to play a game it's
late and I'm tired so I'm probably just
gonna end it here and then I don't know
if I'll stream over the weekends but
maybe I'm playing a tournament where the
round is tomorrow so I do need sleep if
it works out where I do stream during
the tournament probably what I'll do is
just like go over my games on stream so
try and make it as instructive as
possible but for now I'm taking off so
have a good night everyone wherever you
are or good morning and I will see
everyone in the future bye